[Music]
good morning
is this
yeah we're ready I'm gonna try to good
morning good morning everyone good
morning
yeah I hope you all awake hi I'm Dorian
dargon and this is MIT gospel choir we
have a few selections for you guys this
morning I hope you enjoy them Thanks
[Applause]
see
[Music]
you know that because
I'm magic
[Music]
I'm not securities I'm finally happy
I imagine me
mother the ones who hurt me never desert
me can you imagine me say no some
thoughts that try to control me you told
me
[Music]
imagine me
to me I admitted what I was fun to see
you've been in love with someone like me
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine me being strong and not many
people break me down
[Music]
[Applause]
as me
[Music]
finally
[Applause]
I am and it was hard to see you being in
love
[Music]
[Applause]
down down down
[Music]
[Applause]
down
breakdown
[Applause]
[Music]
down
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
down down
[Music]
down
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you good morning my name is Anna
Lorena thomas malthus and i am a senior
in the school in the Sloan School of
Management and the School of urban
studies and planning I will be your
mistress of ceremonies for today's
breakfast celebration please join me in
thanking the MIT gospel choir
[Applause]
in the spirit of our celebration of the
life and legacy of dr. King we would
like you to greet meet or shake hands
with someone near you out of your table
across from you or behind you
welcome to the 35th annual dr. Martin
Luther King jr. celebration I would like
to take this moment to thank president
Susan Hockfield and her husband dr.
Thomas Byrne for hosting this event I
would also like to welcome dr. genetic
oh it is a pleasure to have you here
this morning
furthermore I would like to thank all
the members of the Martin Luther King
jr. celebration subcommittee of the
Presidential Committee on race and
diversity to whom we owe this wonderful
morning when I call your names please
stand up professor Don them on show
assistant director of the global
education and Career Development Center
Debra Lee Berman co-director of Office
of government and community relations
Paul Parra Bono
[Applause]
administrative assistant for the
spectroscopy laboratories Xena Queen
[Applause]
undergraduate administrator of political
science Toby whiner
[Applause]
Reverend John West neck of the MIT Board
of chaplains assistant dean for graduate
education Christopher Jones Chancellor
Philip L clay ex-officio and committee
chair professor J Phillip Thompson thank
you all for contributing to the success
of this event the theme for this year's
breakfast is yes we must achieve
diversity through leadership throughout
the election year we heard yes we can
and now that we did what was necessary
to move the country forward we can turn
our attention to MIT
we the MIT community must do what is
necessary to continue achieving
diversity through leadership to the
nation and beyond this morning's program
will begin with an invocation from
revered John West neck following the
invocation we will have breakfast during
which we will have a musical selection
from the MLT MLK Jr I ap design seminar
group now let us begin the breakfast
with the invocation by Reverend John
West Nick a member of the MIT Board of
chaplains
bless to us all God our celebration this
morn recognizing the clear challenge of
dr. Martin Luther King's vision for all
blessed to us O God new faces in high
places our challenge in progress for
sure less to us O God our mandate to
have for all what many don't our work to
do what others won't bless to us O God
our leadership and many differences the
opportunity we must we lift before you
this morning our table which Grace's us
with food those who prepared it and
bring it and clean our song our talk our
laughter are eating our thought and deed
all we lift to you O God amen
ladies and gentlemen I hope you've
enjoyed your breakfast
we will now continue with the rest of
our program please welcome the MLK IEP
design seminar group who will be
performing an original song entitled
where do we go from here
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so apparently don't have our
meeting years ago skies were grey we're
looking for a brighter day MLK said it
best he had a dream about justice that
was many years ago how much further do
we have to go can you tell me where do
we go from here I remember when the
South had slaves and there was no peace
among races
[Music]
no more shackles but in our minds were
still enslaved opportunity themes so
hope less years ago skies were grey
we're still looking for a brighter day
and okay said it best he had a dream
about a sense that was many years ago
how much further do we have to go can
you tell me where do we go from me
I remember when dr. King was shot add it
to the list of lynchings and beatings
social equality seemed so far wrong when
all the government had white faces
Reaganomics war on drugs and Rodney King
high unemployment low health where we
are right now just isn't good enough
it's gotta be better somewhere
years ago skies were great we're still
looking for a brighter day MLK said it
best he had a dream about justice that
was many years ago how much further do
we have to go can you tell me where do
we go from here earthquakes famine and
disease poverty and poor education you
would think in this time of technology
prejudice would have still plagued our
nation President Obama what are you
doing for us we're ready for change
we've made great leaps but we still have
far to go but we believe it's a brand
new day years ago skies were grey we're
still looking for a brighter day MLK
said it best he had a dream about roses
that was many years ago how much further
do we have to go can you tell me where
do we go from here years ago skies were
grey we're still looking for a brighter
day MLK said it best he had a dream
about justice that was many years ago
how much further do we have to go can
you tell me where do we go from here
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
now I have the pleasure of introducing
two of our very own students Matt
gathers a senior in biological
engineering and joy Johnson a graduate
student inland in electrical engineering
and computer science they will guide us
in a reflection of the life and legacy
of dr. King we will hear first from Matt
gathers Matt
[Applause]
good morning everyone
MIT did something very brave and very
dangerous this morning they gave me my
breakfast before I gave the remarks that
I was supposed to give this morning I
should be halfway back to bed right now
just to teach you all a lesson so good
morning again my name is Matt gathers
I'm a senior and biological engineering
and I'm honored to share some remarks on
the role of diversity in our society I'd
like to begin with a story the story
takes place in the 1940s begins in South
Carolina and it starts when a young man
a young black man named Leroy picks up
his brother rock as he's discharged from
the Navy on the way home Lee and rock
decide but they want to pick up some
cigarettes so they go to a convenience
store Rock goes inside and Lee stays in
the car after a few minutes he hears a
commotion and fearing the worst he goes
inside to investigate when he gets there
he sees three white men all surrounding
Rock telling him that he has no business
in the store and they're beginning to
move in on him that's all he needed to
see he let out a yell and a few minutes
later those three men were unconscious
on the ground Lee and Rock went back
home they told the family what had just
happened and everyone agreed Lee had to
get out of the south if he didn't those
three men probably more would come from
and the police would be of no help
that's not a surprising conclusion in
fact I'm willing to bet that Lee knew
that he would have to get out of the
South the minute he made the decision to
defend his brother that didn't stop him
I have to admire the courage it took for
Lee to assert his god-given rights
better for worse that's an assertion
they're members of my generation we
rarely ever have to make I have to
wonder that if I were faced with the
same challenge what I have had the
courage that Lee happens to be my
grandfather had that morning if we were
up to me to secure the rights of my race
to be brave doing my life on the line
what have I had the courage to do so if
we're up to me to refuse to give up my
seat on
for up to me to demand my seat in school
to get my education would I even be
allowed to Santa this podium this
morning the edge of these questions are
going to remain unknown to me because
the past is past
I can't nor do I want to relive it
that's a bittersweet reality on the one
hand unlikely it's unlikely that I'll
ever have to endure the trials my
answers is faced but on the other hand I
want to share in the work and the
sacrifice that have secured my
inalienable rights as a citizen of this
country and of this world here in the
United States our laws and institutions
now reflect what we know to be right
with respect to race gender and
disability but law has no jurisdiction
over our hearts and minds when we doubt
our classmates calling them the product
of affirmative action when who wish that
someone would go back to his own country
and stop competing with real Americans
for jobs when to remove natural-born
American citizens from our planes and
our trains in our subways because they
resemble a madman who kills innocent to
the name of God we grow ever more
distant from that dream we've done well
in purging racism to hatred from our
laws and institutions but now to realize
dr. King's dream fully we have to purge
it from our hearts and minds the path to
victory in the Second Battle of a Great
War demands that we achieve diversity
through leadership because you see it's
not enough to know that we're created
equally we have to live it every day or
we default to ignorance and hatred in
the absence of diversity stereotype
reigns it's like a parasite that fills
voids of knowledge that should be filled
by personal experience and reason
stereotyped rationalizes places and
blame where it doesn't belong
affirmative action for not getting into
your dream school or the drive for a
diverse workplace for not getting that
promotion you wanted stereotype even
causes members of your own race to look
down on you for something as petty as
your taste in music or something as
important as the person you choose to
marry but most importantly most
dangerously stereotype causes us to
doubt ourselves in my work with
Cambridge public school students the
greatest tragedy is in the low test
score it's not even the palpable fear of
math and science one block away from MIT
it's the fact that these students
honestly don't believe they could grow
up to become an astronaut or physicist
or mathematician or even the president
and why
his little black girls don't grow up to
become CEOs Latinos have no business in
the US Senate and people from this
neighborhood they just don't go to
college yes we must achieve diversity
through leadership because it's only
when these students can see themselves
and people who are breaking the mold
we're changing redefining what it means
to be black to be Hispanic to be a woman
to be gay to be poor that will restore
their sacred right to dream but breaking
that mold takes courage and it takes
leadership the same courage and the same
leadership it took to stand up to
Klansmen the same courage in the same
leadership it took to march on
Washington and yes the same courage and
the same leadership it took my
grandfather to defend his brother in
that store it's his courage in this
leadership that's going to inspire our
youth and our elders alike to abolish
our prejudices towards one another and
to bring it to light of prophecy that
one this happens when we allow freedom
ring when it rings from every village
and every Hamlet every state in every
city we'll be able to speed up that day
when all of God's children black men and
white men Jews and Gentiles Protestants
and Catholics in join hands and singing
the words of the old Negro spiritual
free at last free at last thank God
Almighty were free at last
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Matt we will now
hear from joy Johnson joy
[Applause]
good morning I am joy Johnson a graduate
student in electrical engineering and
computer science from Greensboro North
Carolina North Carolina okay I remember
the day my dad took off work which he
never does to come to my school for a
parent principal meeting which I prayed
he would never have to do it was like a
dark cloud descended upon that high
school I would rather than have been the
rapture than my father but you know I
hadn't cut class I hadn't been suspended
I hadn't even felt a subject but I had
done was apply for scholarship a
scholarship which required my counselor
to send in my transcript and so weeks
went by not hearing anything I started
to begin to think that maybe I wasn't
good enough maybe I didn't deserve it
until one day I got a phone call from
the park scholarships it's a full merit
scholarship to North Carolina State and
they said we're very interested in
interviewing you but we haven't received
your transcript so I began to call
around and seems like no one had
received my transcript but my classmates
all white had been sent and received in
due form ask my counselor about it and
she said I've simply forgot and thus the
reason why my father descended upon
Grimsley high school
it was a high school that neither he nor
my mother could attend for the same
reason she had forgotten that transcript
and many times the intelligent and the
disenfranchised alike suffer from what
psychologists like to call the imposter
syndrome it's a syndrome on which the
sufferers are unable to internalize
their own accomplishments and thus they
feel like they don't deserve them we ask
ourselves do we even belong here what do
we need to do to become as equal as
smart or as intelligent as everyone else
but many times impostor is not us at all
the theme for this celebration is yes we
must but what must we do for so long
we've been achieving inventing and
discovering but for that same time our
achievements have been overlooked our
invention stolen and our discoveries
rediscover and their postures themselves
have been doing it so long that they
perfected the very art of fraud everyone
always speaks of dr. King's I have a
dream speech in which he says I have a
dream that one day this nation will rise
up and live out the true meaning of its
Creed we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal but this statement in itself is
fraudulent these in fact are not the
words of Thomas Jefferson but the words
of his neighbor an Italian immigrant by
the name of Philip mazaya
but what dr. King knew and what we now
know is that the duality of hypocrisy
transcends these just the injustice of
these words what he knew is that the
issues between de facto and de jure law
were not new nor were they original
there are so many untold in justices and
imposters and histories that are simply
forgotten stories of black musicians
like Robert Johnson and Roy brown who in
1947 were playing rock and roll before
Elvis ever picked up a guitar stories of
people like the black sharecroppers of
Tuskegee Alabama who were used
mercilessly as lab rats to come up with
the drugs and treatments that we now use
to treat syphilis whose names are in no
Medical Journal people like Vivian
Thomas who created not only the medical
trials surgical procedures but the
actual instruments to serve the excuse
me to serve infants who have blue baby
syndrome but whose credit was given to
the white
whom he worked for as a janitor and
later a medical apprentice and even in
light of our historical election not
once did I hear the name of shirley
Chisholm who in 1972 became the first
black major party candidate for
president of the United States and the
first female to run for the Democratic
presidential nomination but each
african-american has stories of their
own family members their own relatives
whom the imposter has served this plate
of injustice we have relatives whose
contributions to knowledge have been
ignored and whose rights have been
denied on every front but they fought on
and yet we find ourselves here
so now I ask you do you feel like an
imposter when you walk on this campus do
you ask yourself what must I do
if the mantra is yes we must then what
must we do but I believe that dr. King
put it best and his give us the ballot
address when he said the hour is late
the clock of destiny has taken the time
to act is now he said we must work
passionately and unrelentingly towards
the goal of freedom but we must keep our
hands clean in the struggle
we must not struggle with falsehood hate
or malice we are MIT have an
extraordinary opportunity as even our
own mission states we must work to
advance knowledge and educate students
and science technology and other areas
of scholarship to serve this nation and
this world it doesn't say some students
majority students or minority students
or even all students and I think that
this lack of differentiation is
indicative of the transparency we must
have for true innovation for true
intellectual advancement and it requires
that we have interactions with one
another not only in the labs in the
classrooms and the corridors infinite or
otherwise we must give credit where
credit is due not only in our academic
work but in our everyday lives and this
must begin with acknowledgement speaking
to one another speaking through our
janitors our lab technicians our bus
drivers as eagerly as we speak to our
Institute professors we must show
integrity in our collaborations with
everyone and our fervent pursuit of
solving the world's problems we must
show the world that this institutions
decisions are made on merit
nepotism cronyism or racism we must as
our mission states serve this nation and
this world through our research our
talent and our intellect we must realize
that we are the dream that Marten dream
at that University just across the
Charles River and we must as our
president has charged us in his most
transparent version of those infamous
words we must realize that the time has
come for us to reaffirm our enduring
spirit to choose our better history to
carry forward that promise that precious
gift that that's been passed on from
generation to generation the god-given
promise that all are equal all are free
and all deserve the chance to pursue
their full measure of happiness thank
you
[Applause]
Thank You joy once again I would like to
thank both Matt and joy for their timely
remarks and for letting the word of dr.
King be heard once more now I have the
honor of asking Chancellor Philip clay
to come to the podium and recognize the
2009 Emily Leadership Award ease
Chancellery clay good morning and thank
you very much I'm delighted to follow
Matt and joy because they come from the
same part of the country I do in the
Carolinas and I'm delighted that the
state is still exporting such great
talent last night we had a dinner
honoring the winners of the Martin
Luther King Leadership Awards and to
welcome dr. genetical our speaker we had
a lovely evening in the tradition of
celebrating leadership and we celebrate
it with a particular meaning in mind
that is those who are anointed as our
leaders first our servants dr. King and
several of his sermons underscored that
point that leadership is not purchased
it's not something with which one is
anointed but it is earned through
service so we were pleased to honor last
night and I ask you to recognize several
of our colleagues faculty staff and
students who were given the awards I
will ask them to stand as I call their
names first students Alisha Bob simple
Jason for
their two staff members Deborah liver
Minh
and berry rectly
this is a busy season at Sloane
admission so that's probably yes
and two faculty professor John a Sigmund
and professor Christine Ortiz
thank you very much
[Applause]
Thank You Chancellor clay and
congratulations to the recipients of the
award
please welcome Hiram Etienne an MIT
employee in the electrical engineering
and computer science department who will
now share a special song selection
[Applause]
good morning I remember dr. King talking
about our common denominator and in so
doing he gave his own eulogy and what he
said was was that on that day if you
have somebody speak for me don't have
them stay too long he said don't have
them talk about my degrees don't have
them tell you anything about my hundreds
of awards he was like don't have them
talk about my Nobel Peace Prize he was
like on that day just tell them I was a
drum major for justice I was a drum
major for peace and I tried to help
someone
[Music]
Oh
like the river I've been runnin runnin
ever since it's been
[Music]
but I know
changes gonna come
[Music]
No
maybe on the sky it's better
[Music]
something
to my brother
I say
brother please
[Music]
he lies
this good
I didn't know if I was
[Music]
Sam's coming but handle
achoo
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Hiram that was quite moving
it now gives me great pleasure to
welcome the 16th president of MIT dr.
Susan Hockfield she will she will give
some remarks and proceed to introduce
our keynote speaker dr. Gianetti Kohl
president Hockfield
[Applause]
what a magnificent gift thank you that
was extraordinary actually this
morning's extraordinary good morning it
is indeed a beautiful new day I welcome
you all it is an extraordinary delight
to be here this morning with all of you
on this new day for our campus for the
nation for the world the future looks
extraordinarily bright from where we sit
today I want to particularly welcome
Estella Johnson who is here from the
city of Cambridge she's the director of
economic development and we are always
delighted to have representatives from
our fair city
[Applause]
many thanks or do this morning I want to
particularly thank our hosts for this
morning the Committee on race and
diversity Phil and I were just saying
that on mi t--'s annual calendar this
celebration of dr. King's legacy
continues to be an important landmark
each year is more inspiring than the
year before and we think how in the
world are we going to do this again next
year it gets better and better
this day is a personal inspiration for
each of us to help realize the ideals of
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. I
also want to express my thanks in my
admiration to Pat and joy for their
presentations absolutely breathtaking
and I want to thank you for the
extraordinary standard that you set for
all of us now as you I believe know matt
has been selected as one of mi t--'s two
Rhodes Scholars for next year
it's an extraordinary achievement to be
sure and Matt certainly exemplifies what
the Rhodes Scholarship stands for
they're known for their breadth and
their intensity and I would say that
Matt could not present a more compelling
example from the inspired creativity of
his research in synthetic biology to the
courage of his work as an emergency
medical technician from the generosity
and imagination he's shown in teaching
engineering in the local public schools
and to the discipline and leadership
he's brought to the fencing team where
he has been one of the team stars and
this morning we had a sample of his
extraordinary rhetorical powers he
represents the very best of MIT and it
gives me great pride to know that he's
going to be representing MIT to the
world at Oxford next year now if we have
to let Matt go to other shores there's
some consolation and knowing that joy
will be with us on campus for yet a
little while longer
she's advanced the frontiers of
knowledge in micro and nanofabrication
and in the windows of her spare time and
who knows how she can find any spare
time she opens the world of engineering
to high school girls in Dorchester and
Roxbury joy too represents the best of
MIT and I want to really begin my
remarks in earnest with a line from a
delightful blog that joy manages to keep
amidst all her other activities she
writes for EECS now what I'm gonna quote
is something that happens on the page
just after the page that she has talked
about a life-changing three work three
week trip to India and she writes this I
once heard that your brain is like an
old sweater once it's been stretched
they will never go back to its original
shape
thank the Lord that our minds work that
way now at the celebration last year I
described the excitement of being in the
middle of an unprecedented political
contest remember a year ago last
February and a contest in which as I put
it two candidates with a very serious
chance of winning the presidency of the
United States are an african-american
man and a woman and I would remind you
that a year ago we had no idea the
extraordinary outcome of this year's
election today just a little more than
two weeks since the inauguration of
President Obama President Obama the old
sweater of our national consciousness
has been irreversibly stretched in
magnificent new directions and believe
me it won't go back as inspiring as this
milestone certainly is for young people
it carries an immense power for those of
us who are old enough to have lived in a
very different much less embracing time
now President Obama's election was
momentous in itself but what made the
victory historic was not merely the
identity of our new president it was the
new America that showed through so
clearly in his election President
Obama's support came from young and old
from every race from Americans born in
this country and from Americans who had
immigrated here from around the world
the truth that this election shows is
that originally diverse America does not
await us it is upon us it's our present
and it is our future it is the
wonderfully heterogeneous nation from
which we draw and will continue to draw
most of our faculty students and staff
it is the America we serve as an
Institute and that our students will
go on to lead at MIT we rightly pride
ourselves on inventing the future to
invent this future for this new America
we cannot permit MIT to reflect a nation
of the past that is the context behind
the theme today
yes we must yes we must achieve a higher
level of diversity and inclusion at MIT
and getting to that level calls on
leadership throughout the Institute it
was at the celebration a year ago that I
committed MIT to holding a diversity
leadership Congress as a way to bring
these issues to the top of the
Institute's agenda to accelerate our
progress and to engage the Institute's
distributed leadership distributed
leadership that means those people with
the most direct working responsibility
for making diversity and inclusion a
daily reality at MIT as you know we held
the Congress late last semester calling
together more than 300 academic
administrative and student leaders it
was energizing it was constructive and
it produced lots of good practical ideas
but it also helped us appreciate how
much we still have to do perhaps most
important it introduced to a broad MIT
audience the imperative for us to create
a culture of inclusion and to do that
through shared leadership distributed
leadership at every level throughout the
Institute now certainly I can lead on
this issue and I will others certainly
have led and are leading but you know
it's often the same brave faces that we
see on this issue over and over this
time we're asking everyone to help shift
this great stone of change
it's another lesson we can learn from
the election of President Obama when
many many people feel empowered and
seize opportunities for progress
together they can create unprecedented
change and I can tell you that
flabé 320 Institute leaders who gather
to the Congress have taken up this
charge now what does a culture of
inclusion really mean it means that a
community succeeds in its diversity only
when it looks beyond the numbers alone
and actively creates a culture where
everyone feels valued included and at
ease an environment in which everyone
can do their very best work and while we
didn't arrange this before Matt and joy
have addressed this same challenge let
me be clear a culture of inclusion is
not something we want to pursue because
it's warm or fuzzy or a feel-good idea
we must create a culture of inclusion so
that we can actively capitalize on our
diverse skills and perspectives so that
we can better advance the fundamental
mission of MIT certainly MIT is a place
with unrelenting standards of excellence
we're all proud of that we need to make
it possible for everyone to contribute
at the apex of their ability and if
something the culture is getting in the
way we have to change it creating a
culture of inclusion is simply not an
optional exercise at a very practical
level the feedback we gathered at and
after the Congress called out five
general areas for our attention
retention recruitment climate
communications and accountability well
this morning doesn't offer the time to
delve deeply into these five areas I do
want you to know that we're using the
feedback from the Congress to advance
important change let me give you a
couple of examples first in terms of
retention and climate we're following up
on a number of concrete suggestions
we're going to be creating a best
practices toolkit to help people
understand how to be effective mentors
we're going to be promoting new affinity
groups to build networks of support and
will foster regularly regular highly
visible
opportunities for dialogue between
people who don't share the same
backgrounds or experiences another
example we know we have a lot of work to
do on communication believe it or not
MIT I would say does not get an A in
communication yet we're gonna be
promoting a clear prominent vision of
diversity at MIT and in building these
themes into how MIT defines itself
following the Congress we created a
pretty basic website simply to present
the proceedings to the community we're
now working on a richer site that will
represent MIT as diversity and inclusion
efforts comprehensively it will
highlight the many different inclusion
efforts on campus and there are a whole
lot of them serve as a gateway to useful
resources and let the world know that
we're serious about diversity and
inclusion here at MIT now a number of
you have already offered suggestions and
recommendations and ideas about the
website I would say keep them coming the
website is a work in progress and it
does not yet approach the standards of
an interactive portal that we aspire to
let me just talk a little bit about what
I mean by shared or distributed
leadership and what it looks like one
highlight of the Congress was a dry
observation by dr. Shirley Malcolm of
the triple-a s she said that all too
often what's called a search process is
merely a sort process an exercise and
sifting through known options
this may sound familiar to many of you
so how do we break this all too familiar
pattern here's what one of the
participants wrote I require search
committees to compile a pre search list
of women underrepresented minorities and
stars who are good potential applicants
even if they're not ready to apply this
year I asked them to invite these
individuals to apply or to visit your so
in advance if they're not yet applying
for faculty positions but here comes the
implementation the next year I follow up
and asked what happened to their
previous list
the truth is sometimes solutions can be
as simple as that as long as people in
positions of leadership carry them
through and there are signs that more
leaders are taking this issue on as
their own some department heads have
already reached out to Professor Wesley
Harris our associate provost for faculty
equity to discuss their concrete plans
for making their department's national
leaders in diversity and inclusion
now that distributed leadership to help
individual leaders succeed across the
Institute we need to keep uncovering
practical strategies we need to get the
word out across MIT and we need to
follow up another inspiring example of
distributed leadership is the initiative
on faculty race and diversity under the
leadership of Professor Paula Hammond
seven full time faculty members are
conducting an unprecedented qualitative
and quantitative study of faculty
diversity issues at MIT they expect to
share their findings with all of us next
fall and those findings will define our
challenges and suggest ways to move
forward their shared leadership is
inspiring and it's essential the truth
truth the truth is that in building a
culture of inclusion distributed
leadership is our only path to success
because the real progress in mentoring
and reaching out and locating new talent
must happen step-by-step unit by unit in
labs and offices and residence halls
across all of MIT
now obviously the ideas I've described
are just steps in a very long journey
the progress we see will require broadly
distributed leadership and sustained
efforts centralized and localized big
and small let me address one issue that
is particularly this moment I've heard
the serious concern and the real concern
that our efforts to build a culture of
inclusion could be imperiled by starkly
shrinking budgets which we do indeed
face but let me reassure you that budget
budget pressures will not deflect us
from this work
at the same time it's worth noting that
many of the most important elements of a
culture of inclusion things like
connection conversation kindness these
elements don't cost anything at all it
costs nothing to make sure that every
new hire of whatever background is
paired up with a long-term employee as a
welcoming guide it costs nothing for the
Institute leaders to reach out
proactively to student cultural and
affinity groups and likewise it costs
nothing for those groups occasionally to
halt hold cross-cultural meetings
together for every department had to
check in regularly with all women and
professors of color cost no more than an
occasional cup of coffee surveying
faculty members for the top 20 or 30
students in their lecture courses is
bound to turn up women and students of
color who might be the next Europe's
star and it costs no more than an email
it costs nothing to ask in an annual
review what steps an individual has
taken to build a culture of inclusion or
to educate your colleagues about the
difference between a search and a sort
we cannot and we will not allow tight
budgets to be an excuse for inertia and
inaction before I close I want to be
clear that all the developments I've
discussed today are only the latest
fruits of a process that's been growing
here for many many years I cannot
possibly mention all the groups and
individuals who deserve our gratitude
for their passionate commitment and
perseverance on these issues but I do
want to call out a few of the major
current initiatives including the
Committee on race and diversity which is
led by Professor Phil Thompson and as I
said at the outset the committee posts a
celebration of dr. King the Council on
staff diversity led by Vice President of
Human Resources
Allison Alton is doing very important
work in the staff dimension and Sandra
Harris with her inspired new fame
program this program helps freshmen bond
together multicultural groups beginning
during pre orientation
I also want to acknowledge the very
important leadership of our associate
provost or faculty equity professors
Barbara Liskov and Wesley Harris that
MIT leaders of this caliber
extraordinary caliber have taken on
these roles on behalf of the Institute
demonstrates how serious we are about
accelerating change we're serious about
it because as today's program says yes
we must now it is my extraordinary
pleasure to introduce dr. Ginetta Bicol
let me just give you a little bit of
personal reflection on this morning
dr. Cole is one of those people for me
who you watch in the distance and no
matter how great the distance she stands
as a giant you imagine it would be like
to meet her face to face
someone who has had such a huge impact
and his loom so large in your
imagination and your vision I can tell
you to meet her in person is like a
hurricane going through your mind dr.
Cole welcome to MIT
Ginetta Cole was born to a
prominent african-american family in
Jacksonville Florida in the then deeply
segregated south of this country years
before her birth her great-grandfather
had founded the first insurance agency
in the state of Florida and it was
assumed that she would carry on the
prospering family insurance business but
as a precocious student who went off to
college at the age of 15 Ginetta betch
discovered herself as a scholar and she
had to break it to her family that she
actually planned to study anthropology
many of us in the room has had this
experience of conveying to our family
that we actually weren't going to go in
the direction that they anticipated for
us beginning at Fisk College she
completed her undergraduate work at
Oberlin and herbed her PhD from
Northwestern University
in the years since dr. Cole has become
one of the most effective and beloved
leaders in higher education and a
leading thinker and speaker on questions
of equality and social justice she
currently holds emeritus status at Emory
University where she taught for many
years retiring as presidential
distinguished professor of anthropology
Women's Studies and African American
Studies dr. Cole is also president
emeritus of both of the nation's two
historically black colleges for women
Bennett College for Women in Spelman
College
she's the only individual to have held
both of these presidencies what's more
when she took on the presidency of
Spelman College in 1987 she became the
first African American woman to serve in
that role in Spellman's a hundred and
seven year history from 2004 to 2006 dr.
Cole served as the chair of the board of
the United Way of America again the
first person of color to lead that
national organization today she chairs
the board of the Ginetta Bicol global
diversity and inclusion Institute
founded at Bennett College for women let
me give one final word dr. Cole was once
asked about the experience of being
first and so many of her endeavors she
replied in one way it's very
exhilarating you can almost take
yourself too seriously until you realize
that something is probably wrong being
the first probably says why has it taken
so long and I can tell you it takes huge
courage to be the first I hope that in
bringing diversity and inclusion to the
top of mi t--'s agenda and in bringing
dr. Cole to our campus we're moving
closer to the day when the firsts will
be far behind us while the great task of
inventing the future lies ahead it is my
privilege to ask you to join me in
giving dr. Cole a very warm welcome to
MIT
[Applause]
sister president Susan Hockfield and I'm
going to turn to find the brother
Chancellor Philip clay my sisters and
brothers of the faculty and of the staff
and but of course I would greet every
single sister and brother of this
student body without them we wouldn't
have any reason you know to be here I
also want to acknowledge that there are
sisters and brothers from the larger
community who are here including our
sister who was acknowledged now in case
I've left anybody out let me just say
sisters and brothers all good morning
and if I can draw on one of the many
religious traditions in this great
country of ours
I would not only say good morning I
would say it's a great gettin up mornin
now you might ask why I would begin my
talk by a greeting each of you with that
language
sisters and brothers all clearly it
comes from growing in the south growing
up in the south and in particular in an
african-american family that was deeply
deeply rooted in a black church but it
also comes from participating in the
civil rights movement and the Black
Power movement of the 60s you know when
young and not so young folk of a range
of backgrounds and attributes put their
lives on the line in the interest of
justice they were sisters and brothers
and being trained as an anthropologist I
remember one of the greatest lessons
that I learned and that is a kinship is
ultimately really not about biology
it's about attitudes and behavior and
shared vision if we are all here
together on this particular occasion
I've got to assume that you are my
sisters and my brothers it is of course
a very very special occasion here at MIT
when once again you stop and you pay
tribute to dr. Martin Luther King jr.
the loving man who courageously carried
Gandhi's nonviolent philosophy through
some of the most turbulent times America
has ever known Nina Simone called dr.
King the dark prince of peace all over
our country during the last few weeks
and into this one and perhaps a few more
people of every hue and background
acknowledged that 80 years ago Martin
Luther King jr. was born and in his ever
so brief stay on earth he dared to
imagine believe in and work for the
fulfillment of a mighty mighty mighty
dream a dream of racial equality I
believe that if dr. King had lived
beyond the 38 years that he gave to us
that he would have described and worked
for and even larger dream and we hear it
hinted at when he talked about the
Beloved Community it would be a dream
that of course would include that day
when no one would be judged by the color
of their skin but I think dr. King would
have increasingly articulated a dream of
a day when we would cease to judge
anyone based on their gender based on
their sexual orientation
their age religion class nationality
physical and mental abilities or
disabilities today these years after dr.
King so brilliantly and movingly
delivered what we have come to call his
I have a dream speech we are challenged
to ask has that dream of racial equality
been fulfilled let me but put the
question in the context of the
incredibly significant event that has
taken place in our nation the folk that
grew me in Jacksonville would use an
expression they wouldn't just say our
nation they would say our zone namely
that on January the 20th the year 2009
Barack Obama the son of a Kenyan man and
a Kansan white mom became the 44th
president of the United States of
America following that extraordinary
moment in the history and herstory of
our nation and our world the first
family of America a black family moved
into the white house the very White
House that slaves helped to build after
senator or then-senator Obama won the
election many of us could just not stop
saying
we would greet each other and we would
hug and we would say I never thought it
would happen what's the rest of it oh
but my sisters and my brothers all it
has happened now some have argued that
the election of Barack Obama as the
president of the United States
signals that America is now a
post-racial Society folk who gue be at
this part would say well his election
certainly does say to us that in our
land race is no longer a barrier to the
highest office in America but in my view
it does not mean that racism has ceased
to exist it is simply possible for white
folk to accept a black leader in the
highest office in the land and still
support institutionalized racism and as
you know when institutional
institutionalized racism goes and took
our roots with poverty the results are
devastating for our nation's people of
color it is that double jeopardy that
double whammy of racism and poverty that
leads to Native Americans African
Americans Latinos suffering
disproportionately from a range of
diseases it leads to these communities
experiencing twice as much unemployed
as white Americans it is behind the
Association of people of color with
substandard housing and it is this
double jeopardy of racism and poverty
that propels such high dropout rates for
black and Latino students and that sends
more of our young black and brown men to
prison than to colleges and universities
individual acts of racism also persist
in our nation the election of President
Obama with all of the joy that we felt
it also ignited a number of outbursts of
bigotry Jesse Washington an Associated
Press journalist wrote these words just
a few days after the November 4th
election cross burnings school children
chanting assassinate Obama black figures
hung from nuisance racial epithets
scrawled on homes and cars such
incidents around our country referring
to president-elect Barack Obama before
he became president began to dampen the
post-election glow of racial progress
and harmony highlighting the stubborn
racism that remains in America and yet
my sisters and my brothers all despite
such incidents as the brother said he
was searching for we can Laos we can
declare it change has come and yet we
are still such a mighty mighty long way
away from being able to declare victory
over bigotry and discrimination the
great african-american scholar and
activist dr. w eb Dubois once said that
the problem of the 20th century is the
problem of the color line well here we
are in the 21st century we have yet to
eradicate the problem of the color line
and there are so many more lines that we
human beings have constructed to divide
us lines based as you know on gender and
class and religion and nationality on
sexual orientation on age on physical
and mental abilities because various
forms of bigotry and discrimination are
so widespread and so tenacious many are
led to say and to believe that you know
it's it's just human nature to dislike
people who are different from who you
are to create systems of inequality
based on those differences I could sure
call on anthropology but why don't I
just call on common sense to say no big
doesn't a
bigotry is not just human nature excuse
me
and you know what it ain't I need my
water please and you know what bigotry
it ain't genetic it's learned and if it
is learned guess what it can be
unlearned and even more thrilling we
could just stop teaching it now I'm not
naive to think that we can rid the world
of bigotry by declaring a moratorium on
teaching it but it would help
and how well I know that bigotry and
discrimination are about power and about
privilege it's not easy for folk who
have power and privilege to decide to
give it up you remember what Frederick
Douglass said power concedes nothing
without a struggle it never did and it
never will we have to offer to those who
have it a more rewarding alternative
Martin Luther King Jr's alternative we
need to imagine and work toward making a
world making a world where a difference
doesn't make any more difference
we need to envision and then create
communities where everyone is respected
and invited to the table so that their
voices can be heard so that their
experiences can help to propel the work
that needs to be done and if there isn't
enough room at the table guess what
we've got to learn how to build bigger
tables here in our nation power and
privilege based on race and gender stand
out and so as an african-american woman
I know what it is like not to have white
skin privilege I know what it is like
not to have male privilege but it is
ever so important that I acknowledge and
deal with the reality that there is some
power and some privilege
that I do have I clearly have power and
privilege as someone who is of the
upper-middle class I have power and
privilege as someone who is a
heterosexual a Christian and physically
able doll though the last one of my
friends one of my friends who does so
much work in the communities that are
differently abled she says being
physically able just wait for all of us
it's ultimately a temporary condition
this reality that each of us has some
form of power and privilege flows from
the fact that each of us has multiple
identities and it's ever so important
for us to be aware of those identities
and to guard against efforts to
characterize us in singular terms sister
president Susan referred to the enormous
excitement when we had an
african-american man and a white
American woman as candidates for the
presidency but it was also a moment of
enormous tension for some of us as we
were being lobbied with the words that
if you are a woman you have no choice
Hillary Rodham Clinton is your candidate
if you are an african-american you have
no choice Barack Obama is your candidate
for those of us who are twofers
what were we to do the answer I think is
that we were first to own our multiple
identities and then we were to make a
decision based on more than a candidates
race or gender I want to share one other
reality about this stuff that we call
bigotry and discrimination it is this
said unfortunately being the victim of
one form of bigotry or discrimination
does not immune one from victimizing
others for example excuse me some white
women who have been the victims of
sexism can systematically practice
racism some black folk who have known
the bitter sting of racism can be
intensely homophobic and practice
heterosexism some people who are Jewish
and have been the victims of
anti-semitism can Harbor feelings and in
fact carry out actions that stem from
Islamophobia so my sisters and brothers
all of this prestigious university based
on the points that I have tried to make
about the ongoing challenges to what is
simply a reality human diversity
challenges that are expressed as bigotry
and as discrimination what might I ask
of you ask of you who
are now already leaders or poised to be
leaders I hope it doesn't sound arrogant
for me to say that I think what I am
about to ask of you dr. Martin Luther
King jr. where he here would also ask of
you and I am convinced that if the
brother President Barack Hussein Obama
were here that he would ask this of you
no less what I'm about to ask please
know that I ask also of myself first
learn how you learned are your
prejudices that is interrogate yourself
about your particular journey around
questions of diversity and inclusion
there was so many moments when our
brother Matt and our sister joy made
those studying presentations that I was
I was simply moved but notice that in
each of those presentations they had
interrogated themselves about the
journey that they're on they had asked
of themselves how they had learned in
each case to be soldiers in opposition
to bigotry and discrimination and for
those of you who are parents or thinking
about becoming parents I asked this
quite simply of you teach your children
well but refuse to teach them bigotry I
also
ask that you get in touch with your
multiple identities and once you do so
you must never ever ever again let
anyone interact with you on the basis of
one alone I had the great privilege and
joy of teaching at Hunter College at a
moment when one of my Shiro's Audrey
Lord was there yeah one of my she rose
cuz forever here on the world as at
least one Shiro organoid who many of you
will know became the port laureate of
the state of New York but was clearly
then as she is now among the most
recognized black feminist lesbian
writers when Audrey Lord would stand up
to speak she would inevitably begin by
saying I am Audrey Lord a black woman
feminist lesbian mother poet warrior
and I remember that she would sometimes
say don't you dare deny me any of the
parts of Who I am I don't wake up in the
morning and decide from 7:00 to 8:00
I'll be black and get on with it because
by 8:00 I've got to become a woman and
I've got until 9 o'clock before I turn
into a lesbian I also urge you to
honestly examine your own power and
privilege for if you are to avoid using
your power and privilege in ways that
exploit and oppress others then you've
got to be in touch with what power and
privilege you have and finally in terms
of what I ask of each of you asking this
of you to encourage exercising
leadership to create and sustain greater
diversity and inclusion at MIT let me
say this on that while very impressive
steps have been taken here at MIT under
the transformative leadership of our
sister president Hockfield and while
there is ongoing work of the MIT
diversity leadership Congress I came all
the way from Atlanta Georgia to tell you
that that is not enough that each of you
must take personal responsibility for
helping to change this mighty
institution
that means in concrete terms some of the
actions that sister president Susan
shared this morning and so I'm going to
be repetitive for a little bit but
remember when it comes to education and
action
repetition is good for the soul and so I
say first that you've got to make sure
that the curriculum at MIT has moved
away from the 3w use you know about the
three WS that's a curriculum that is far
too Western to white and to womanless
that means if you are to indeed
transform this mighty institution into a
still mightier one that every department
must refuse to move forward with a
faculty or a staff search if there isn't
a diverse pool of candidates who - what
sister Shirley Malcolm said about
searching versus sorting let us say a
men and a women too
[Applause]
to bring about greater diversity and
inclusion at MIT it means not only
recruiting a diverse class of students
each and every year it really must mean
creating an inclusive culture so that
students of color students of the LGBT
community students who are differently
abled students of all underrepresented
groups can proudly say this is my
university or better put institute it's
time now for me to bring some closure
but I'm gonna do it in the tradition of
great black preachers who tell you they
are going to begin to conclude
and it takes a while to get there I want
to do so by telling you a story and I
again turned to sister joy and to
brother Matt to say that in addition to
all of your brilliance in your humanity
you have discovered the power of
storytelling the story that I'm gonna
tell is not my own it was a favorite of
another of my Shiro's her name was I
need to say man first out of respect
Fannie Lou Hamer and you will remember
her perhaps best for the line that she
used she said I'm sick and tired of
being but I like many of us who say that
and then just proceeded to do nothing
about it
this daughter of sharecroppers this
woman of the Mississippi Delta went on
to do something about being sick and
tired of racism and injustice and as you
know she led a many a black sister and
brother up those steps of a state house
to register to vote and for that act of
courage and being an American the water
hose would push her to the ground the
billy clubs would come across her edge
and jail became a place she knew well
fannie lou hamer
loved to tell this story at the end of a
talk because she said it would answer
the question who is to do the work
who is responsible if we can phrase it
in terms of your theme of this gathering
who are the leaders who are the leaders
that have the responsibility to bring
greater diversity and inclusion to MIT
the last line of the story will answer
the question it's a wonderful story it's
about some young boys who one day
decided to play hooky from school well
there was no point in playing they leave
from school unless they could get into
some trouble thought they and they
proceeded to do so the ringleader caught
a bird and they just figured out they
thought very ingenious ways of torturing
that poor bird to within an inch of its
life but then they grow they grew bored
with that and the ringleader said I got
an idea I'll tell you what we're gonna
do we're gonna go up the road a piece
and we're gonna ask that old lady up
there a question she will be incapable
of answering well what's the question
said one of his buddies said you
remember that bird we just finished
messing with I'm gonna take that bird
and I'm gonna put it behind my back and
then I'm gonna say old lady old lady
this bird that I have behind my back is
it dead or isn't alive now if the old
lady says why why the bird is dead I'm
gonna release my hands it will fly away
she'll be wrong but if to my question
old lady is the bird dead or alive if
she says why the bird is alive I'm gonna
crush it and she will be wrong so they
did their hi-fi's and the way they went
to find the Oh
lady when they did the ringleader with
that disrespectful tone that
characterizes far from all but some of
our young uns the ringleader said old
lady old lady you gonna answer my
question
and with that humility and decency and
compassion the characterizes so many of
our elders the old lady said why why yes
my son I will try he said well all right
old lady remember now what the old lady
says is the answer to the question who
is responsible for bringing greater
diversity and inclusion to this great
Institute all right old lady the ring
ladies ring leader said see this bird
I'm gonna put it behind my back now you
tell me is the bird dead or is it alive
and she thought and thought and thought
and then this is what the old lady said
she said hmm the bird why why it's in
your hands that's the answer it's not
sister president Susan it's not brother
Chancellor Phil it's not any committee
including the diversity Congress leaders
changing this Massachusetts Institute of
Technology to be an incredibly welcoming
place to the good Lord to her many
people
you know what that work is in your hands
and in some other place and always I
know it's also in mind thank you very
much
[Applause]
please join me in thanking dr. genetical
for her heartfelt words
[Applause]
please join me in welcoming Provost
Rafael Reif who will now recognize the
2008 2009 Martin Luther King jr.
visiting professors and visiting
scholars Provost Reif what an incredible
humbling experience it is to stay in
this podium after this remarkable
presentation dr. Cole I should say
sister dr. coleye I want to thank you
for this thank you for this moving and
very spiring speech the MLK visiting
professors and scholars program honors
the life and legacy of dr. Martin Luther
King jr. by inviting and recognizing the
contributions of outstanding scholars in
scientists and asking them to spend some
time at MIT to enrich our campus this
program as all of you know is being run
out of the office of associate provost
Wesley Harris so I'm going to be
identifying the America scholars of this
year and I'm going to be asking them to
please stand up I think most of you are
here and I'll try as best I can to
embarrass you while you're standing up
dr. Dolores Acevedo Garcia is she here
let me read what she is here doing and
where she come from
she is right now a visiting associate
professor in the department of urban
studies and planning she is an associate
professor at the Harvard School of
Public Health she received her PhD in
public affairs and her master's in
public affairs in Urban and Regional
Planning both from Princeton
she received dr. Acevedo Garcia her BA
in public administration at the center
of international studies in El Colegio
de Mexico Mexico City her research
interests include the effect of social
determinants such as residential
segregation and immigrant integration on
health disparities especially among
racial and ethnic lines and the role of
non health policies such as housing
policies immigrant policies in reducing
those disparities professor Leonard
Daniel please stand up
professor Daniel is a visiting assistant
professor in our department of Aaron are
he received his bachelor's and master's
degree in Sciences with highest honors
in mechanical engineering from the
Soviet Academy of Science in Moscow and
a PhD degree from the University of
London Queen Mary and Imperial College
after working as a senior research
scientist at UK defense evaluation
research agency and at the European
Space Agency he joined the department of
mechanical engineering of the University
of New Orleans where he is currently a
research professor he is also a visiting
professor at the University of
California at Berkeley he teaches and
conducts research in the areas aerospace
composites structural dynamics
nanomaterials Bao inspired and
intelligent structures with applications
to morphing aircraft intelligent and
many area vehicles and intelligent
vehicle and highway systems for Daniel
thank you for being with us
professor Thomas clave
you have to stand up and suffer
professor glaive is a visiting professor
in a program on writing and humanities
humanistic studies his home institution
is the stage University of New York in
big mental he received his MFA in
creative writing from Brown University
in his be a wooden major in English and
a minor in Latin American Studies from
Bowdoin College professor glaive
travelled as a Fulbright Scholar to
Jamaica where he studied Jamaican
historiography and Caribbean
intellectual and literary traditions
while in Jamaica professor glaive worked
on issues of social justice and helped
found the Jamaica forum for lesbians all
sexuals and gays a passionate writer and
political activist professor glaive has
taught at the University of Virginia
Cleveland State Brown Indiana and Naropa
University and is presently an assistant
professor of English general literature
and rhetoric at sunny pig Hampton he has
received numerous fellowships and awards
and I'm gonna just mention one he was
named a writer on the verge by the
Village Voice in 2004 Glade thank you
professor Daly Joaquin
professor you Hakeem is with us a
visiting assistant professor in the
Media Arts and Sciences program after
his electrical engineering PhD from
Michigan State University
he developed speech processing and
sensor network algorithms at Lockheed
Martin later as a faculty member at
Tulane University professor him turned
this signal processing algorithms toward
the monitoring of wildlife at MIT is
Media Lab he has taught the class of
technology for observing natural
environments and held seminars on
bounding ellipsoid optimization theory
professor your team aspires to tackle
public health problems such as malaria
through sensor based monitoring of
responsible vectors where they are most
needed protecting thank you
dr. cow Paris
dr. Paris here
but your Paris is a visiting scholar in
our Women's and Gender Studies he holds
an MA in dance theory and dance in
higher education from NYU in New York
University and a PhD in the instance and
cultural Theory from Temple University
he has taught technique and dance
related courses in Spain at the theater
Institute of Madrid Barcelona Sevilla in
at Cal art he has served on the faculty
at NYU and Long Island University and
more recently as adjunct professor in
african-american history and race and
ethnicity at John Jay College of
Criminal Justice in New York City dr.
Paris has performed among with many of
the prominent dance companies of today
among them Olatunji African dance Martha
Graham and Alvin Ailey but MIT dr. Paris
will teach a class in the traditions of
American dance gender and autobiography
in addition he will work toward
expanding his research into a book that
will include a philosophical
intersection between selected issues in
black dance and wider contemporary
cultural studies context dr. Paris thank
you very much
and one more doctor Latanya Sweeney
dr. Sweeney is a visiting professor in
our ECS department electric engineering
computer science she is an associate
professor of computer science technology
and policy in the school of computer
science at CMU Kennedy Mellon University
she also founded and serves as a
director of the data privacy lab which
works with real world stakeholders to
solve today's privacy technology
problems her work involves creating
technologies and related policies with
provable guarantees of privacy
protection while allowing society to
collect and share person specific
information for many worthy purposes she
received her PhD in computer science
from MIT the next one may not get that
much applause her undergraduate degree
in computer science was from Harvard
University
she has received many awards from many
numerous organization dr. Sweeney thank
you very much for being
before I conclude I would like to
recognize a very special visitor we have
today at MIT
this is dr. Victor McCreary they do you
mind standing up I know you're surprised
Victor came to visit us yesterday I
believe and he is making time to be with
us this morning Victor is the president
of the national organization of black
chemists and chemical engineers and that
is his night job
Victor is the business area executive
for science and technology for the Johns
Hopkins University Applied Physics
Laboratory and his assistant department
head of the Milton Eisenhower Research
Center he got his doctoral degree from
Howard University in physical chemistry
and had a long and outstanding career
and has received numerous awards and
honors who were delighted that he's here
with us today and helping us to carry
forward the legacy of Martin Luther King
without let me just ask you to please
join me to thank and congratulate all
those extremely successful scholars who
are choosing to spend some time with us
thanks again
[Applause]
we will now continue with some
announcements relevant to our
celebration throughout this week
those of you on campus may have had the
pleasure of seeing the installation
located in Lobby 10 design and
constructed by their dr. Martin Luther
King jr. IEP seminar the installation is
part of a seminar called the Martin
Luther King jr. IEP design seminar which
is offered each year during January to
facilitate the design and construction
of an installation placed in Lobby 10
and spec special projects organized in
conjunction with MIT annual celebration
of dr. King students in the class read
materials and watch videos about dr.
King and other important civil and human
rights leaders in the US and beyond the
theme for this year's installation is
injustice anywhere is a threat to
justice everywhere we invite you to read
the insert included with your program to
learn more about the numerous activities
implemented by this year's class MIT is
proud to announce that Lisa Owens is
this year's recipient of the 2009 YMCA
of Greater Boston black achieved
achievers award lisa has been recognized
as a minority staff employee who had
simplifies MIT standard of excellence
lisa is a chief radiologic technologist
at MIT medical Lisa
[Applause]
MIT will host MC squared
also known as multicultural conference
on March 7th the multicultural
conference works to bring students
together across race ethnicity gender
religion nationality sexual orientation
and other aspects of cultural identity
the one-day conference is open to all
students with an interest in issues of
diversity and inclusion at MIT and
beyond the organizers are black out prop
the black out on Prop 8 invites the
audience to join them tonight at 6 p.m.
in W 24:07 for black out on Prop 8 a
discussion on the media scapegoating of
the african-american community following
the passing of prop 8 in California the
discussion will focus on correcting our
assumptions addressing LGBT and racial
tensions and what we can do at MIT to
push for LBGT rights now please welcome
back Hiram Etienne and the pianist from
the MIT Gospel Choir to lead us in
singing the Negro national anthem lift
every voice and sing by James Weldon
Johnson we ask that you that you join in
and sing the lyrics are located on the
back of your program please stand
that's such a great time today actually
I just like to say that this was an
awesome ceremony
singing with me lift every voice and
sing till
[Music]
bring with the heart
and I read your see
[Music]
in the skies
the reserved
[Music]
Linsey
Singh
[Music]
please in
[Applause]
[Music]
days
tears has been
[Music]
this guy
stray from the places
[Music]
now by the grace of God brothers and
sisters go forth into the world shaped
by a dream motivated by an imperative
that we must and empowered by courage to
live lives worthy of those on whose
shoulders we stand let the congregation
say Amen right again amen
[Applause]